le prométhée au début de ce journal nous
allons humer ensemble le doux parfum
d'yvonne avec notre invité jean-pierre
marielle bonsoir bonsoir très heureux de
vous accueillir
alors le parfum d'yvonne c'est quoi
dites le aux téléspectateurs c'est un
film de ce fut une poterie seconde qui
est tiré d'un roman de modiano le mot
dialogue il s'appelle le biais de la
triste avec hippolyte girardot et sandra
mariani nombreuses distributions et moi
même alors on va parler d'histoire après
extrait regarde mesdames messieurs nous
vous attendons vous pouvez faire
descendre vos bagages bien arriver un
jour ou l'autre madame n'y est pour rien
il vient de recevoir un ordre de mission
signé de la reine des belges comptant
des mains de la reine des neiges
je ne vous ai pas tout dit madame la
reine des belges seigneur que ce que
vous transportez là-dedans voisine mais
quel point je vous de vous entendre et
toutes ces merdes
vous êtes donc la reine des belges soit
la reine des belges c'est qui la reine
des belges dans le parfum d'yvonne la
reine des vins dont la très jeune c'est
le docteur rené massat semble un peu
bizarre mais c'est comme ça d'un
personnage assez extravagant fantasque
fantasque bizarre paumé un peu comme
tous les personnages de modiano et pour
s'amuser comme ça et dit que il est la
reine astrid la haine des belges il ya
une sorte de provocation là dedans parce
que c'est un personnage assez
provocateur parce que parce que
malheureux difficile ou pas pour écouter
tous les personnages de modiano sont les
personnages louches d'izard toujours des
personnages un peu de lisières alors
c'est toujours surprenant à jouer mais
c'est vraiment très très très
intéressant moi ça faisait des années
moi je suis à lecteurs de modiano ça
faisait des années je vis avec quand
va-t-on adapter un bouquin de modiano
parce qu'on sent le film a quand on lui
ai alors c'est fait c'est fait avec
bonheur parce que le réalisateur et
l'actrice lecomte retrouve un peu le ton
de modiano
je crois que les sensibilités sont
accordés magnifiquement entre deux il ya
une vraie rang alors docteur m'a dit la
reine des belges rencontre victor chmar
un drôle de conte c'est hippolyte
girardot et yvonne de personnages aussi
trouble que vous et c'est toujours un
jeune homme dans les romans de modiano
qui est comme ça qui traque qui traquent
sont passés quittera une sorte de ce une
sorte de quête poétique et ce jeune
homme retrouve là dans ces petites
villas toujours frontalière rencontre
des personnages bizarres loup ça se
passe moment de la guerre d'algérie
c'est toujours dans des périodes un peu
trouble face les bouquins de modiano et
c'est cesser c'est toujours le même
sujet si vous voulez mais là je pense
qu'il ya une vraie rencontre entre un
l'art d'un metteur en scène et lardin
dans les crimes les plus difficiles en
trois minutes après un journal fait de
séquences réelles et brutale comme ça
qui s'entrechoquent de s'arrêter ça sur
un film ou sur un livret de tenter de
raconter une histoire mais j'ai le
sentiment que dans ceux dans ce film
livre dans ce livre devenu film il ya
comme une fuite des trois personnages
qui voudraient fuir la vie la vie réelle
et qu'ils s'engagent dans une vie rêvée
par concept aussi le mensonge
ah oui mais ça se
très juste mais ça ça fait partie de
l'univers et de la fascination qui opère
dans les romans de modiano espèce de
quête douloureuse de fuite et on ne sait
pas très bien où ils veulent aller ce
qu'ils veulent fuir ils fuient leur vie
leur vie tous les jours leur vie banale
la vie de cette vie provinciale qu'il
est qui les étouffe un petit peu oui
c'est certain c'est c'est très
cinématographique parce que je ne sais
pas à nous lever comme moi comparaissent
le roman de modiano de l'année on a des
images qui vous pour qu'on est poursuivi
par des images
il ya plein de romans de modiano qui
j'ai le sentiment que ce sont des films
que j'ai vus un livre de ce 2 mondial ne
se raconte pas il se livre je dirais
même chose du film de patrice leconte
il doit se voir merci jean pierre
marielle jean